W tym rozdziale przedstawimy ramy
do myślenia o środowiskach komputerowych
które można zastosować zarówno na laptopie
jak i skalować aż do superkomputerów
pod koniec tego rozdziału
zrozumiesz podstawowe pojęcie zasobów komputerowych
i to, jak się ze sobą wiążą
czym więc są zasoby komputerowe? Krótko mówiąc
to składniki tworzące system komputerowy
mamy CPU, czyli centralną jednostkę przetwarzającą
która wykonuje większość instrukcji, mamy pamięć
czyli RAM, który tymczasowo przechowuje dane
i instrukcje programu
oraz mamy GPU, czyli graficzne jednostki przetwarzające
przeznaczone do renderowania grafiki
ale mogą być też używane do obliczeń ogólnego przeznaczenia
wymagających dużego przetwarzania równoległego
jak symulacje naukowe, analityka danych czy uczenie maszynowe
te zasoby współpracują ze sobą przy wykonywaniu programów
a każdy ma własne jednostki miary
na przykład jednostki CPU mierzy się w rdzeniach
i taktowaniu zegara, a pamięć mierzy się w bajtach
w giga, mega i terabajtach
dla każdego z naszych problemów
będziemy potrzebować zestawu zasobów
żeby je wykonać
kluczowe jest rozważenie zasobów potrzebnych do ich wykonania
efektywnie — lokalizacja, gdzie wykonywane są komponenty programu
i przepustowość infrastruktury je łączącej
odgrywają istotną rolę
w określaniu ogólnej wydajności
na przykład GPU może być szybkie przy obliczaniu konkretnych części
naszego programu, ale jeśli wczytanie programu do pamięci GPU
zajmuje więcej czasu niż oszczędzamy
może być szybciej użyć zamiast tego CPU
porozmawiajmy teraz o skalowaniu klasycznych zasobów
mamy dwa podejścia: skalowanie pionowe
i skalowanie poziome; skalowanie pionowe polega na zwiększaniu
mocy pojedynczego zasobu
jak użycie mocniejszego CPU lub większej ilości pamięci
w jednym fizycznym węźle
gdzie węzeł to jednostka klastra obliczeniowego obejmująca wiele
zasobów; skalowanie poziome
polega na dodawaniu kolejnych zasobów
jak wiele CPU lub GPU
do współpracy w jednym węźle lub wielu węzłach
oba podejścia mają swoje zalety
i wady, a wybór zależy od konkretnego zastosowania
i wymagań; przedstawmy nowy typ zasobu
zasoby kwantowe przetwarzają informacje kwantowe
z użyciem kwantowej jednostki przetwarzającej, czyli QPU; QPU
to cały system odpowiedzialny
za przyjmowanie wykonywalnego zestawu instrukcji kwantowych
lub quantum circuit i zwracanie
dokładnej odpowiedzi; oznacza to
że QPU zawiera jeden lub więcej kwantowych chipów
na przykład procesor kwantowy IBM
a także wiele dodatkowych komponentów
w lodówce rozcieńczającej
otaczającej chip kwantowy
jak kwantowe wzmacniacze, elektronika sterująca
i klasyczny komputer potrzebny
do zadań takich jak przechowywanie instrukcji
i przebiegów w pamięci, gromadzenie wyników
i przyszłe dekodowanie korekcji błędów
ogólnie zasoby kwantowe mierzy się
pod względem jakości, warstwowej skali wierności
liczby qubitów
i szybkości — operacji warstwy circuit na
sekundę, czyli CLOPS; dziś będziemy traktować chip kwantowy
jako jednostkę miary, podobnie jak systemy zarządzania zasobami
traktują GPU — nie przez liczbę rdzeni
ale przez całe jednostki; a co ze skalowaniem?
Podobnie jak klasyczne zasoby, skalowanie zasobów kwantowych może
być też podzielone na pionowe
i poziome; skalowanie pionowe
polegałoby na zwiększaniu liczby qubitów na chiplet
lub na chip
skalowanie poziome polegałoby na łączeniu chipów
za pomocą couplera lub klasycznych połączeń
mając tę definicję za sobą
porozmawiajmy o zarządzaniu zasobami
zarządzanie zasobami w infrastrukturze komputerowej odnosi się
do procesu planowania
przydzielania i kontrolowania użycia zasobów obliczeniowych
takich jak CPU, pamięć, przestrzeń dyskowa
i przepustowość sieci, w celu zapewnienia efektywnego
i skutecznego wykorzystania zasobów
możesz myśleć o zarządzaniu zasobami
jak o wielowymiarowej grze w Tetris, gdzie klocki
to wymagania twoich zadań
a każdy wymiar to jednostka zasobu; ogólnym celem
jest dopasowanie tych bloków zadań do sześcianu
wszystkich dostępnych zasobów; zarządzanie zasobami
to bardzo trudne zadanie i różne centra obliczeniowe stosują
różne taktyki do konfigurowania swojej infrastruktury
zgodnie z konkretnymi potrzebami swoich użytkowników
żeby zastosować pojęcia, których właśnie się nauczyliśmy, użyjemy
Slurm; Slurm to oprogramowanie open source
do zarządzania zasobami
na potrzeby demonstracji
mam lokalną konfigurację z trzema wirtualnymi węzłami
możemy uzyskać informacje o tych węzłach obliczeniowych
uruchamiając polecenie scontrol
mamy dwie partycje, czyli grupy węzłów
normal i quantum; partycja normal składa się z węzłów
mających dostęp wyłącznie do klasycznych zasobów
a partycja quantum ma dostęp do zasobów kwantowych
najpierw uruchommy prosty
klasyczny przykład hello world w Slurm
najpierw potrzebujemy samego programu hello world.
A oto nasz program, który po prostu wypisuje hello
world.
Teraz musimy powiedzieć menedżerowi zasobów
jakich zasobów potrzebujemy do uruchomienia tego programu
jak omówiliśmy, Slurm udostępnia sposób na określenie
wszystkich metadanych zadania za pomocą
skryptu powłoki
ze specyficznymi dla Slurm adnotacjami
te adnotacje pozwalają określić wymagania zasobów
parametry harmonogramowania i wiele więcej.
Możemy sprawdzić nasz skrypt do zgłaszania zadań
i tutaj masz specyfikację partycji
ile węzłów potrzebujemy, ile zadań na węzeł będziemy
uruchamiać, ile CPU na zadanie użyjemy
i który skrypt chcemy uruchomić
a to jest nasz program hello world.
Żeby zgłosić zadanie do wykonania, wystarczy uruchomić
jedno polecenie, czyli sbatch
i podać nasz skrypt jako argument
możemy sprawdzić kolejkę wykonania
i zobaczyć, że nasz program hello world działa
na partycji normal w węźle c1
kiedy zadanie się skończy, możemy sprawdzić wyniki
przeglądając plik wyjściowy.
I to tyle.
Interesuje nas też używanie zasobów kwantowych
dlatego stwórzmy prosty program hello world w Qiskit.
Oto nasz program w Qiskit, który zawiera wszystkie
niezbędne kroki tworzenia circuit
optymalizacji, wykonania i postprzetwarzania.
I tu wszystkie koncepty programistyczne, o których mówiliśmy
quantum circuit, transpiler
i prymitywy Qiskit
teraz musimy stworzyć skrypt zgłoszeniowy
jak poprzednio, ale tutaj określamy
wymagania dotyczące zasobów kwantowych
skoro określiliśmy zasoby
i partycję w klastrze
jakie zasoby kwantowe są dostępne
prymitywy Qiskit użyją
przydzielonych zasobów do wykonania obliczeń kwantowych.
Teraz musimy uruchomić nasz program.
A kiedy zadanie się skończy, możemy sprawdzić wyniki.
I oto nasza wartość oczekiwana.
I to tyle, jeśli chodzi o zarządzanie zasobami
w następnej sekcji będziemy rozmawiać
o modelach programowania